what's going on guys this is rob and i
feel like i should launch a merch line
i don't know if i should i wear hats all
the time i feel like i should make a
geek culture explained hat
i don't know let me know what you think
so i'm probably a little bit late to
this party by the time i'm recording
this but i have to do this right we're
going to
push the room around up to saturday
because i feel like this is something
that we need to talk about
so in the loki documentary where they
basically run over how they made loki
they had a deleted scene really like a
series of deleted scenes right it was
more like a montage
but loki was supposed to get the
infinity gauntlet so the way this played
out is that you basically ended up
having like michael walden who's like
the head guy that's getting the whole
show together
and that you had a white board behind
him and this white board had like all
these different things on it right these
different plot points stuff like that
and one of them was that loki was
supposed to escape to a different time
period
and then do a whole bunch of mysterious
stuff right like have a bunch of sex
not even lying that's one of the things
that were there but one of the things he
was also supposed to do
was basically get all the infinity
stones for himself and then assemble the
infinity gauntlet and then use the
infinity gauntlet to basically take
power
do a bunch of other mischievous stuff
have a lot more sex and then things just
kind of go back to normal right he
realizes like okay this isn't really
interesting or amazing he goes back to
the tva the infinity stones d
power and then mobius shows him the full
might of the time durian's authority
right so
it was only supposed to be like a really
really short segment but i feel like
that would have been cool now
having said that maybe that's the scene
that we saw from the trailer where you
had loki who like came down off the
throne
that looked like he had taken over as
like the ruler of asgard or something
along those lines
but luckily with the infinity stones
sounds amazing man
and i don't know why they scrapped that
right it was only supposed to be a
montage like a short thing
sure they could have left out like all
the dirty stuff i didn't have to include
all that
but loki with the infinity gauntlet
would have been awesome
and i'm so sad that we didn't get to see
that because i thought it would just it
would have been so cool
but having said that you know when it
comes to the to the idea of the infinity
gauntlet there's room for that and i
think that one of the things you're
actually going to end up seeing in the
future
is you're actually going to find out
that there are like what if universes
where that actually happened it's one of
the things a lot of people tend to
forget when it comes to the return of
the multiverse
is that the multiverse is an answer to
the question whatever can happen
will happen there's just an alternate
reality out there where it takes place
right so there's an alternate universe
where loki never stopped
impersonating odin in the marvel
cinematic universe and the play they put
on
basically went on forever and matt damon
plays loki until the end of time
i have no idea but there are alternate
universes where that kind of stuff takes
place
and and i want to see that alternate
reality where loki gets the infinity
gauntlet i don't care about the other
dirty stuff
but i want to see the alternate reality
where he gets the infinity on it because
i can only imagine how that
happens right i can only imagine how
that plays out it seems like it could be
pretty quick
right like i don't think it would have
all the other stuff in there but i think
you'd basically see loki take the
gauntlet for himself
he'd kill thanos right just like that
like thanos would be gone probably snap
right no pun intended but probably snap
santa's out of existence
and then seize control of asgard for
himself right because a lot of people
ask the question
when they were watching avengers end
game and that kind of stuff like could
hella have defeated thanos
could like odin have defeated thanos in
the comics no
not even by a little bit but when it
comes to the marvel cinematic universe
probably i mean i don't really see any
reason why they couldn't thanos with the
infinity gauntlet no
like there's no way they would have won
right thanos would have just eradicated
them
with the greatest of ease with the
infinity gauntlet it really begs the
question would it work on
sir technically the infinity gauntlet
does affect
everything in the universe which
includes pocket dimensions
in universes right everything inside a
universe
and because the realm of like certain
and and hella and all those characters
are in pocket dimensions that if they'd
survived to the events we'll assuming
like we assume certain survived there's
nothing to indicate that he died but
like if he was alive during the events
of infinity war in avengers end game
yeah it stands for reason he would have
been blinked out of existence we've
never seen it happen but in mobile
comics they've largely alluded to the
idea the infinity gauntlet
can kill people who are just massively
powerful right i mean
it defeated cosmic entities why wouldn't
it defeat certain
but nonetheless you know it's one of
these things where having that kind of a
story in the mcu would have been
great right it would have been
absolutely awesome but even as i think
about that
i'm kind of led to believe it probably
would have played out the same way
right uh it's really kind of hard to
tell because one of the great things
about the loki tv show
is it forced loki to think about things
he wouldn't normally think about
right like would loki have become the
person that we saw in the loki tv show
by the time this series ended had it not
been for his exposure to the tva
had he not been forced to witness the
fact that like his actions led to the
death of his mom
in terms of mobius sitting him in a
chair and making him watch that
would we have seen him like we have
turned into that kind of person i don't
think so man like i don't know so it
could have been one of these things
where he's like he got the infinity
gauntlet it was like yeah man and it
goes nuts with power right just goes
absolutely bonkers
and never like atones for his past
mistakes and never realizes that like
there's more out there to life than like
glorious purpose
i don't know if i agree with that
statement
but it would be it's a cool thing right
it's an awesome thing so i don't know
you know it's a cool little segment and
i really wish they'd included it in the
show
that really begs the question what else
did they leave out
in the show right because i really wish
they would have included old king loki
for those of you guys who don't know
what that is right like
loki the all butcher we talked about
that before here on the channel but loki
the all butcher is
nuts loki the all butcher is basically a
version of loki who killed all the
superheroes on earth he killed everybody
on earth
right like all the humans and everything
and even all the superheroes he
basically eradicated all life on earth
and then there's a point where he gets
the the all-black necro sword
and basically becomes like this being
this imbued with a living abyss the
living abyss is basically the substance
that created like the symbiotes and
marvel comics like venom carnage all
those guys
it was originally wielded by null but he
eventually gets that and then just
becomes like the all butcher ultimately
he's killed by gore when gore comes back
but
it's still a cool thing right like just
that like the twisted version of loki
from the future
he looks evil man like he do he looks
like such a villain
and it looks amazing but i would love to
have seen that in the movies man like i
would love to have seen that
in the marvel cinematic universe i feel
like it would have been great but let me
know down in the comment section right
let me know down in the comments
what other like alternate possibilities
of loki you want to see
right assuming let's let's say for
example they do in the marvel cinematic
universe what they do in the comics
at least these days anyway where they
craft a whole what if line of comics
around a singular event right like
infinity where like thanos showed up on
earth
and he was facing off against like his
son and the inhumans and ultimately
defeated by his son
and avengers were like out in space
fighting this group called the builders
who were gonna like eradicate the earth
but there's like a what is story where
like what if thanos had joined the
avengers in space
and helped them like fight the builders
uh what if that had happened right so
like what did they end up doing that
with a loki tv show right so like what
if loki and it's just like all these
possible alternate realities
where things went different in the loki
tv series or like other realities where
like loki's are there we just didn't get
to see what those loki's looked like
like what version of loki would you want
to see let me know that down in the
comments because i'm curious to see what
your all's responses are man but i got
to say
not seeing loki with the infinity
gauntlet is vastly disappointing
it's like one of those things where i
wish they hadn't told me
because i never would have known what i
was missing
but nonetheless it's a cool little
revelation to have there so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
thank you for watching and i will catch
you all later peace